[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
my
[Music]
huh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
cool
and that's going to be a treble and
those are the kinds of mistakes
that are magnified when we're talking
about a game down the stretch
[Applause]
and not allowing the shooter even an
inch of breathing room on that one
that's his great defense forcing his man
into a difficult attempt
he dishes it to henry
pasta hopkins
it's just what the doctor ordered here
boy have they needed him
here in the fourth
[Applause]
he kicks it to henry
[Applause]
there's the pass to hopkins
and the officials call a traveling
violation
pass to henry
passes to hopkins al adams
he found the open space for mid range
just maybe rushed
his release a little bit
he's got the hot hand right now as long
as he can keep getting open they've
got to keep feeding him
he lobs it up
[Applause]
really starting to attack on the
interior here showing a much more
physical presence
here in the second half
to the middle
pass to hopkins
to the wing on the left
henry passes to hopkins
here's adams
the pass to hopkins
not easy to keep him from converting
those i mean the d has to be
airtight
and he's made seven of his last eight
shots that
is the definition of clutch
it isn't the d that causes this that's
just a loss of concentration
and you gotta love the effort i mean he
battles just as hard on the inside
as he does on the perimeter
inside
adams outside passes it to hopkins
there's the dish to henry
to the inside
his individual effort has been
outstanding tonight and it's helped him
grab the lead
hopkins the pass to henry
[Applause]
adams right side
picked away
pass to hopkins
not shot from outside there's no doubt
about that spreading the floor
and getting them up
pass to henry
and that's just great work there to get
in the shooter's face and then
go and corral that back door the pass to
hopkins
over to the wing
passes it to hopkins
well with the role he's on this quarter
they're going to keep going to him
get that lead even bigger kicks to henry
and adam sends it back you got to be
careful around indeed when he's around
he's capable of coming up with these
blocks
ask to henry
[Applause]
just call him the closer he won't
let this team lose adams right side
hopkins the pass to adams
[Applause]
pass to henry
to the left wing
now the pass to hopkins always going up
for the alley-oop here
try trying to go for an alley-oop but
excellent defense and anticipation there
to stop it
dish is it to henry
[Applause]
stolen
[Music]
ready
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
so
[Music]
right
leonard kicks to wagner
white finds wagner
and if you let the little guy get
airborne before you slide over to block
him out
he can and will embarrass you on the
boards
[Applause]
jackson dishes to leonard
[Applause]
pass to wagner and it's white
top of the key kicks it out to leonard
white trying to get open
[Applause]
jackson passes to leonard now white
back to wagner
and leonard has it in the corner
[Applause]
the ketchup when you can't hit shots
this is a quarter he
like to forget
jackson kicks to leonard
passes it to white
and they've really gotten on track here
in the second half after that shaky
start
the field goal percentage steadily
climbing they couldn't make anything
in that first break
and memo to the rest of the team
continue to get him the basketball he's
clearly delivering here in the fourth
entered on the wing
[Applause]
pass to newton
[Applause]
[Applause]
pass to white back to wagner
inside he's hot this quarter
getting the shots he wants and he's
delivering
now the dish to jackson there's the
lobna jackson
stolen away nice job to interrupt the
alley-oop attempt there
for him tonight a real nice lift for
their offense
leonard finds white
up top wagner
[Applause]
jackson trying to break this has been a
tremendous quarter for him
everything he puts up now looks like
it's going in
[Music]
[Music]
inside
to the paint
passes it to garrett
[Applause]
to the inside
back to young sent that and he gets it
back
brown outside
he's unguardable nobody been able to
contain him
here in the fourth quarter now four or
five from the field
has to garrett the emphatic rejection
rejected by young get that out of there
that's all
timing right there drew holiday
continuing hustle play
it's stolen by brown
[Applause]
and here in the fourth he's carrying
this team right now five of
seven from the field nelson dishes to
young
throws it up high
he kicks it to garrett
[Applause]
and there's the pass to garrett
pasta young he dishes it to garrett
[Applause]
inside
dishes at the nelson
and garrett picks the young
floats it up for young
brown outside
[Applause]
ashton nelson
brown outside
nelson
kicks to young to the middle
rejection and that goes out of bounds
and they retain possession
garrett the pass to nelson
that's tipped
young pass it to garrett
back to young
it's stolen by brown
[Applause]
to the left side wing
and there's the pass to ramsey
and he lobs it up toward the rim
love to see him battling and go get it
tricks this quarter they can't figure
out how to stop it
pastor ramsey now here's james
the art of rebounding in a nutshell box
out hold your ground and call
in the miss
and it ends up out of bounds and they'll
keep possession
on the wing james pastor ramsey
down low
[Applause]
magnificent rejection and he delivers
another blow something's gotten into him
this quarter he's
carrying them offensively
pasta james
to the wing on the left
you